[Music]
motivation
is the experience of wanting something
or wanting to avoid it
when we study how we get motivated to
learn develop
and succeed we can identify two contrary
forces
extrinsic and intrinsic ones
[Music]
on the one hand we want to belong desire
to be loved
and seek to get the attention we think
we deserve we
are motivated extrinsically by rewards
in order to progress socially
[Music]
on the other hand we strive to explore
things that are satisfying in themselves
disregarding rewards we are motivated
intrinsically
by a natural curiosity which we follow
because it feels right
the opinions of others don't matter
to understand why we probably need a
good mix of both
let's imagine two four-year-old children
both grow up in families that want only
the best for their kids
but have completely opposing views on
how to motivate them to succeed
tom's parents believe that all their boy
needs is love
to not undermine his intrinsic interests
they never praise him or use rewards
eventually they decide not to give him
any feedback at all
fearing it could corrupt his free mind
over the years tom develops an immense
capacity to imagine
spending most of his time playing by
himself by being allowed to follow his
passions
he learns what he likes and what he
doesn't but tom doesn't learn what
others expect and gets easily irritated
when asked to do something in a
particular way
mira's parents believe that their
precious little girl needs clear rules
about what's good and what's not
they see it as their duty to help meera
learn by providing precise and
actionable feedback on all aspects of
her young life
mira spends her days in preschool music
and ballet lessons
over the years she gets exceptionally
good at the things that please the
adults around her
however since there is neither time to
play nor to relax
she doesn't discover her own interests
being alone bores her
[Music]
at 14 tom is independent and begins
writing science fiction
he realizes that he isn't quite like his
friends and spends most of his time at
the library
when he shares his writing others can't
quite relate
at the same age mira is at the top of
her class and has plenty of friends and
admirers
she knows what is expected of her and
makes sure to meet those expectations
sometimes the pressure becomes
unbearable although that's her secret
by the day he turns 21 tom has a unique
perspective of the world
he is intelligent but doesn't like to
work for money and hence is always broke
he hates the idea of conforming to
conventional norms and is annoyed if
someone interferes with his creative
expression
at this point tom knows a lot about
himself but doesn't connect well with
others
to him people seem to follow rules
without questioning them just like sheep
integrating into the society is
difficult at this point and he begins to
search for utopia
mira makes it into a top medical school
where she realizes she'll never be top
of the class again
once that place seems out of reach her
motivation drops and she wonders if
medicine
actually interests her since quitting is
no option
she takes up a second major and runs for
student council president
soon mira will know everything about
what others expect
but nothing about what she likes for
herself all her life
she has just listened driven by external
feedback loops
at this point she's almost lost the
ability to question the norms of the
society she grew up in
listening to our heart can tell us who
we are but not how to be happy among
others
listening to others can motivate us to
be a part of their world but doesn't
teach us if that world is ours
this is why it's probably good for the
two to go together
then we can learn what we want and get
the feedback we need in order to stay
motivated to explore new roads into a
better society
a large body of research shows that
balancing the two forces
is not straightforward one meta-analysis
of 128 studies examined the effects of
extrinsic rewards on intrinsic
motivation
while most rewards significantly
undermined our intrinsic interest
positive feedback which is an extrinsic
motivator inspires us to keep going
put simply honest words of encouragement
get us going
while money or gifts undermine our inner
drive
what about you do you listen to your
heart or to the voices of society
and from your personal experience which
of the two eventually takes your
decision
share your thoughts and check the
description to dive deeper into the
topic
sprouts videos are published under the
creative commons license
that means our videos are free and
anyone can download
edit and play them for personal use and
public schools
governments and non-profit organizations
can also use them for training
online courses or designing new
curriculums
to help us stay independent and support
our work you can join our patrons and
contribute
just visit patreon.com sprouts even one
dollar can make a difference